We have a voicemail number, which you can call any
time. That number is two one nine two David P..
Here's a good question about
Trump's treatment regimen
for Corona virus. Take a listen to this.
Hey, David. This is Dave from
California. And we've all seen the
medication that Trump is taking.
Don't you think it's surprising
the end of the group orders?
D.M. D.M. Doctor by hydroxy chloroquine was not
on the list of medication that stream medicine.
Trump has been touting forever
wanted everybody to take it.
I just find it quite odd. Nobody, not
even a reporter asked that question.
So it was actually asked yesterday, yesterday
and in the briefing that Donald Trump's doctor,
Sean Connelly, gave before Trump left Walter
Reed. He was asked, why didn't Trump take hydroxy
chloroquine, given how much he's been touting it?
It would be natural for him to take it. You would
think, Sean Connelly said, we discussed a lot of
things, but I'm not going to go into why he did or
didn't take anything in particular. We're just
going to focus on what he did take, of course.
The answer is because it wouldn't work. It doesn't
work. It's been debunked. That's why they didn't
give it to Donald Trump. And this is, again, more
supporting evidence that what they say publicly
is just optics and posturing and politics. It's
not fact. It's not reality. We have a great bonus
show planned for you today. We will talk about
New Zealand handling a very small second wave
of Corona virus, continuing to do really well. We
will talk about how speaking two languages appears
to protect against dementia and cognitive decline.
Very interesting new study. We will also talk
about the arrest of anti virus dude, John McAfee,
who has now been arrested in Spain on tax evasion
charges. All of those stories and more on today's
bonus show. Get the bonus show, my friends. Get
the bonus show. Sign up for a membership at join
Pacman dot com and you will be given instant
access to the world famous bonus show.
I will see you then.